calling for justice yesterday the family  of a man killed in a car crash last year  again called for justice at a vigil that  was held yesterday  eric echevarria was killed near fort  apache and blue diamond his  car hit by a speeding passing vehicle  driven by former bishop gorman  basketball star and unlv recruit zeon  collins collins attorney have attorneys  have asked a judge to throw out the  charges  and javario's wife says she's not going  to let that happen  he was high which was proven and he was  going 88 miles an hour which was also  proven and he killed my husband which is  also proven so  to have this wiped away i i can't do it  i just  i can't accept that i will never accept  that in  july a judge will decide whether to drop  the charges against  collins alex